it's the same in any sort of area of
life right whether it's your training or
any kind of error in what you're trying
to do it's those sets and reps and it's
the boring stuff it compounds over time
that's going to give you the desired
outcome most people just can't create
order around those few things they can
create order around one or two areas of
their life but as soon as you've got to
create order around the kitchen around
training around work around family
around social occasions something falls
apart it's the people that have the
ability to do those four or five things
that then people think oh they've got
all their [ __ ] together they've just
spent a bit of time trying to create
that order find what works iterated on
the process when it does work just allow
compounding interest take care of things
when it doesn't work try and improve it
ollie marchon welcome michelle
thanks for having me chris
good to be back very good to have you
back man how's the last year been for
you talk to me
eventful as i'm sure it has been for
many people um but good fun i think a
lot's gone on um has it been a year
since it's probably been longer than a
year since we spoke yeah year in two
months
yeah so lots changed my second son has
arrived
so enzo is now in this world he's
actually one years old tomorrow which is
flown by
um so
learning's become apparent i think we
spoke we touched on sort of parenting
last time um when i was on but yeah
learning to parent two kids has been fun
challenging um how much harder is two
versus one
i'm sure many people that have got two
will understand it's
you can't even compare it to honest
because it's not just twice as hard it's
more than twice a second
it's it's far more than twice as hard
because
you you just can't you could
any sort of plan or or structure that
you try and implement even you know with
anything just goes out the window
because these are babies we're talking
about so there is no it's just sort of
there's no self-regulation for them just
things happen and and you just got to
deal with it so yeah things like being
on time leaving the house
feeding nappies sleep all that kind of
stuff goes out the window um i mentioned
last time i was on that i'm very
fortunate that my wife is very good at
this sort of thing so she makes things a
lot easier but yeah that's that's been a
really good um challenge um i still
think it's probably one area of my life
that i don't take as naturally to
but it's something that you know i
really enjoy the um yeah really enjoy
the challenge
uh other things gyms are back open which
is a big part of what we do at march on
obviously without with our facilities so
that's been cool um we've had some
growth in areas of the business due to
what we kind of what went on when the
gym was closed um in the online space
and kind of awareness and the
community's grown a lot more
what we kind of offer our community has
grown that's come with some personnel
change as well so the team's grown
people have kind of been and gone and
others have kind of joined and and i
guess
taken us to um another level because
we've got more hands on deck
um
what else well what's different about
you now what's different about the guy
that stood in front of me now than the
guy that was stood in front of me 14
months ago
okay so i guess the main difference is
i'm not locked up at home so i feel like
life is life is back to a million and
one miles an hour whereas back then it
was very much it was very very for
someone like me it was very slowed down
um there was a lot of constraints placed
on me and at the time i probably
perceived that as being
quite inhibiting but
upon reflection there's probably a lot
of positives that that were that came
out of that time and that maybe if i'd
have sat back and slowed down a little
bit or just been deeper with my thoughts
a little bit at the time i'd have seen a
lot more positives in that it's only now
kind of looking back in hindsight that i
realized that those things were actually
great for someone like me um i think in
day to day a big change for me is that
i've come off the coaching floor so the
identity that i had back then as ali
martian the the coach and personal
trainer which of course i still kind of
hold on to that but fundamentally
day-to-day i don't really do any
coaching or personal training so i guess
i'm kind of faking it if i if i still
say that i am i am a coach i'm a coach
of sorts but less so on the gym floor
what do you do now
this is such a good question um
to be honest
i don't actually know and i know that
sounds that sounds really bad
it sounds really bad it's part of yeah
it's part of the bit i'm sure we'll kind
of come on to it as like this identity
change piece
that seems to be happening too often or
more often than not now in my life i
thought the original identity change was
from sort of post rugby coming into this
personal training jamona sort of realm
um
obviously i'm still the gym owner but
the day-to-day running of the gym isn't
necessarily all in my hands now there's
people that sit in sort of management
roles there operational roles um
i guess if we if we distill it back to
the two businesses march on and the psca
so march one being the physical gym the
online training nutrition and all the
bits that will kind of come with that
there's some roles in in amongst that
and there's also the pfca which is the
professional fitness coaches association
which stands for kind of education and
mentorship of personal trainers and gym
owners
so
i guess i'm the key person of influence
and i hate the word influence within
those two businesses i.e
the person that kind of pulls things
together and makes things happen a bit
from a strategic level as well and i
guess just like boots on the ground as
well in different areas with contacts
and networking that that can kind of
like kick doors down and get in there
and get things get things moving um
i think a lot of what i do now giving
those people in management roles is to
work collaboratively collaboratively
with them
to
enable them a little bit more facilitate
their kind of growth and development and
also that area of the business just try
and make sure that we are constantly
trying to iterate on that um and make it
as good as we can
what's it like then so you said that you
were this guy
on the gym floor being a pt always been
an athlete always been involved in
training and now you're
you know closer to an executive board
member who's got to be you know ops
director logistics making sure that the
branding guidelines are done right
what were some of the challenges that
you went through letting go of that old
version of you
i think just the terminology is there is
like the board member sort of ceo thing
i'm like make you want to throw up in
your mind in your mouth it does it does
a little bit but it's like how can you
be a ceo when you're just a personal
trainer i still kind of have that
mindset
um i guess the main difference is being
for someone who's always been
appointment based
alarm would go off at a certain time
every day because i've got to be
somewhere for six a.m ordinarily you
know that's that's the latest i would
ever start at 6 00 a.m on the gym floor
session starts or jim opens
and you you're gonna
when you're in the moment on that quote
unquote shift of delivering personal
training there is nothing really else
that you should be thinking about
ideally towards the latter stages of my
career on the gym floor there was plenty
of things i was thinking about outside
of coaching because i knew things needed
to get get done
and whilst i was on the roll on the gym
floor and no one else was in the role of
doing those things it could kind of eat
away at me which actually made my
coaching practice um
not as good shall we shall we say so the
big difference being like i say alarm
routine
structure there working a shift and then
trying to fit things in in the rest of
my day um
and then constantly feeling as though
it's always constantly feels as though
you never really escape things
but now you're just i'm just escaping or
trying to escape and i'm not even trying
to escape them i now feel as i can't
escape different things one big change
significant change in september of last
year when jim's did reopen was that
for the first time in my life i decided
not to have an alarm so i decided to
make sure that you know i was waking up
when my body decided that i was ready to
awake
be awake i mean
kids don't really allow for that so i
was often being being woken up by by one
of the two boys
but that was a big change and like i say
i'd find myself waking up almost feeling
guilty
that i hadn't set an alarm
i was waking up a little bit later
ordinarily what sort of time
still still i'd say around half five six
o'clock latest um sometimes if the boys
would sleep in a little bit further a
little bit later than that then i'll
probably sleep in a little bit more as
well um and then that just sort of like
starts that cycle of guilt because you
know you've not had the alarm
you're not going to work they're sort of
i suppose it's almost like a
a tangible thing where you feel as
though your your value or your impact on
the business
is you being there in front of the
customers on the gym floor in front of
the members delivering the product
whereas now i wasn't delivering the
product i was almost like trying to
think of like where can i take the
product and what is the product what is
the bit that i can now influence so
that for a long a large period i'd say
sort of three months so it was took me a
while to try and get into a routine you
know i had my home office i had um at
the time it was just the home office we
weren't in the offices where we are now
so i was like where is where's work and
where's pleasure like if i'm working
from home and also you get this kind of
it never really happened and it was
never verbalized and i'm sure they never
really thought that but you almost think
like the the people around you that have
always seen you as the first person in
the gym and maybe the last person there
or you're always you know in and around
when our product was just delivering
personal training it's kind of like as
olly just got his feet up now because
you know he's no longer on the gym floor
so that took a little bit of time to get
used to
it's so interesting thinking about this
over the last year i don't think it's
just business owners that have had this
a lot of people were either given
restrictions or opportunities covid was
a stimulus and the response to that
stimulus from many people was a desire
to change something
what should i change should i go down a
different route with my relationships
with my daily routine i got exposed to
something online that really sort of
changed the way that i see the world or
i created new good habits or i built bad
habits over this period of time
and the outcome of that has been for a
lot of people that they've needed to let
go of a version of themselves before
that perhaps wasn't serving them quite
so well or maybe that version was
serving them fine and they wanted to
scale up and level up to okay what's the
new version of this
and yeah that guilt is
a big deal man like when you've attached
your sense of self-worth to being ollie
march on pt on the gym floor letting go
of that must be a challenge
yeah the biggest challenge is just a
lack of purpose every day like when you
when you don't know what that thing is
that you're going to go and
attack or where you need to be or
there's not an appointment it's almost
like
the destiny of all the yeah that my sort
of fate was back in my own hands and the
destiny of where this business was going
to try and go was it was all had to be
self-actualized by me it's like
now it's like my ideas and all these
things i said i was going to do if i
didn't have any constraints around me
like now i don't have the constraints
you know gym's open i've taken myself
off the gym floor i now have my proxy
that opened up a large period of time
which i can go and fill with good work
so now it's down to me to go and do the
good work so
i mean
thankfully the people around me gave me
a bit of time to sort of like
build in you know get my feet under the
table with that new role um
and not just not just the the team
members in the around me and the coaches
but also the gym members because for
them it's a bit of a change as well
they're kind of you know like i said
that
yeah that adds to the kill as well it's
like
where's ollie is he ever going to get
back on the gym floor is he you know
what's what's it what's he up to now
and i think the position some days the
position i've kind of moved into which
is a little bit of like a
i guess in the corporate world it's a
bit of a schmoozer you know you're just
kind of going out and building
relationships and networking and looking
at opportunities and and those sort of
things like for
and i think a lot of my day-to-day now
is actually via social media in fact i'd
say 75 of my day is taken up by
social media and there's not an initial
you know return on the investment from
what you're doing on social media and
that's nothing i've never even looked
for the return investment on social
media
it's kind of happened by default
but i guess compounding on that over
time and the sort of success leaving the
clues here it's like the more time i can
spend communicating with our community
and the people that have kind of bought
into following my journey the others
journey the story of kind of march on
what it stands for
the more
it actually enables these other things
that we're trying to bring out to
actually be successful
last time that we spoke you were very
routined and regimented
how are you operating now what are the
disciplines and the processes that you
have in place
the routine and the routine that i had
in place before was by
that came about by having more time
right you're trying to fill your time
with with stuff particularly during
lockdown where you feel as though you're
doing something of of of worth right of
of value so by having almost like this
back-to-back
order events that take go go on through
your day you feel as though you're
actually working and doing something and
by nature of what lockdown kind of gave
people like me well everyone really you
had all this time that you could try and
fill and i think i got guilty of just
trying to overfill it but at the time i
didn't i couldn't identify that because
it was a situation that we're in that
was the environment that we had as
things begin to open back up and change
and you know and family changes business
changes the day-to-day changes all those
things that you attached yourself to
you could no longer do
because it was it was probably probably
too much i think we've all we've all
been there as well we try and optimize
every area of our morning routine every
hour throughout the day every era of how
we you know how we you know go to bed at
night as well um
and i've done that in the past a little
bit when i came out came out of rugby
before and it and it always sort of
comes off the back of this identity
change bit
it's like well i'm struggling to kind of
work out where my value actually lies
and where my purpose is and what i
should be doing so i'm just going to
make sure that i feel as i'm doing all
these things
that are actually moving the needle
forward by putting all this order and
structure in place
so
it's changed a lot and you know that
that starts with things like i mentioned
before with the with the alarms and
things but i think i was just guilty of
over optimizing
and and with all that comes a just a
lack of enjoyment of where you kind of
are um
and i think just on top of that
for me i i'm someone that needs to just
keep reminding myself to just be a
little bit more present and live in the
moment a little bit a little bit more
it's not that i need to try and improve
everything i'm trying to do the grass
isn't always going to be greener just
kind of work where your feet are and
just try and water the grass where
you're standing
and i think that's kind of a bit of a
lesson from that time as well but only
looking back at it now would you have
been able to keep going the way that you
were like how close do you think that
you were to burn out
i think you can keep go i think you can
always keep going if you're if you're
incredibly selfish and it is just all
about you like you but where i was at 25
26 years old
even before that right so when i was
growing up in my early 20s like when i
was you know university trying to get
back into rugby the only thing that
mattered to me was rugby so any girl
that came into my life or any social
occasion that came into my life it was
always secondary too i need to be a
full-time rugby player
same sort of thing happened at 20 26 27
when i came out of rugby and it's now
like i'm going to go into being this
business owner and open a gym everything
came second to i'm going to open it open
a gym and i surrounded i made my entire
day and life
just what the way i thought i needed to
be to be a successful gym owner or
business owner
and what happens in that process is that
the people around you
soon get pissed off and just you know
you're just not a very likable person
because you're not well-rounded enough
you don't have enough balance yeah
you're just uni-dimensional right
exactly um so i do and i burnt myself
out
in that sort of 27 28 yes or 26 27 28
that sort of that sort of stage
um
i think just with a little bit more
maturity and being a bit wiser and also
the fact that there are people that
actually depend on me my two sons and
things i can't go
so far down that road because it's not
fair which is a large part of um
we might bring it up later on it's a
large part of why i've i've stopped
being
competitive
in like the fitness space for example
people kind of often ask that why don't
you compete so much
because i'm not really the sort of i'm
not able to compete and it just be like
just take part and compete which is a
bit sad and i i'm kind of working on my
ability to do that actually last weekend
i competed in national fitness games as
a last minute sort of replacement and i
was very much in the in the mindset of
like i'm really not
fit or strong enough to be doing this to
the standard i want to be doing it
and i feel a bit exposed but i was able
to do it and just have a lot lots of fun
just sort of like just taking part so
i'm hoping that like i say at this sort
of age i'm coming into now and where my
life is and all the all the
responsibilities i have that i can just
allow
myself just to take part in things for
the pure enjoyment of stuff and that's
been missing for a long time
i think we're very much absolutist
creatures right we have it's very easy
to be completely on your diet absolutely
focused never breaking it or to be a
complete slob but to be able to stay on
your diet for a couple of weeks then
break it once then stay on your diet for
a couple of weeks and break it once like
the messy middle is exactly where people
find challenges and it's because we
attach our sense of identity to the
things that we are doing i am a
professional rugby player i am a
nightclub promoter now i am a podcaster
now i am a gym owner whatever it might
be
and when you
when you bring these constraints in on
life what you end up doing is you
actually wrangle some of the chaos of
what's going on into a bit of order and
you think okay the i have a narrow set
of parameters with which i can tweak and
also that i need to be worried about so
jack butcher the guy that does visualize
value it's a huge sort of don't even
know what you call it he literally just
creates concepts out of famous quotes
and makes them graphically look great
being on the show and he spoke about the
fact that one of the first things he
wanted to do remembering he's a graphic
designer his background is in making
things look pretty the first thing that
he did was give himself very hard and
fast rules about what they could look
like
it's always going to be white on black
it was always going to be the same font
it was always going to be a geometric
design so what he did was he brought the
constraints in of the his chosen pursuit
so that he didn't have to worry about
colors fonts design
and it meant that he focused on the
highest point of contribution for him
which is how well can i visualize the
concept i'm actually trying to do so he
wrangled all of this chaos this
unlimited number of colors and fonts and
styles
wrangled that in and what it permitted
him to do was to really really focus on
one piece of creativity but i think what
a lot of people do with it as well is
it gives them a sense of comfort
it makes them feel comfortable because
they know okay i just need to get up at
5 30 a.m focus on my my clients get
myself into the gym bin it when i'm when
i'm training so on and so forth but when
you go right okay
draw yourself back a little bit can we
have
you
showing up when you need to in training
but knowing that you don't need to give
it everything because you have other
priorities in there you also have a
priority of being a dad you also have a
priority of being a leader or a
businessman and again this comes back to
the identity change thing that you've
seen and a lot of people will have done
coming out of kovid who the [ __ ] am i
who the [ __ ] am i after a pandemic's
happened and it's kind of i haven't
really had a lot of conversations now
retrospectively looking back at what the
pandemic did to people i think everyone
was so sick of talking about it talking
about lockdowns and about oh bro it's so
boring isn't it and gyms aren't open and
stuff like that
but i think that now is the time to
really
get some great learning experiences
out of your period during lockdown look
back and say okay what am i like what
what's the texture of my mind like when
i get under stress
what is this where are the sort of
places that i go to in terms of coping
mechanisms do i sleep in or do i find
myself really drilling down on stuff
do i need more friends was my support
structure not there all of these sort of
things um but yeah bringing those
constraints in and focusing sort of
narrow and deep i think is a very common
almost a coping strategy to high
pressure because it narrows your focus
onto one thing
i think narrow and deep something i need
to
concern myself a little bit more because
so so many opportunities that's the
thing i get caught up now now because i
have a little bit more it's not
necessarily more time that because
there's
my my attention is brought um to
different things that are going on in
the industry it allows more
opportunities and it's almost like i
just need to make sure that i remain
focused on a few things and that's
actually been something i've been trying
to work on with
um mentioned it before before we started
sort of ambassador deals and working
with different bits and pieces that i've
done in the past which again was part of
my identity you know i work with these
brands there's a mutual benefit to both
parties and that's you know who
identified as in in different sort of
sects of the sectors of the industry but
actually just trying to
take take some of those things away from
you know off my plate offload these
things from my plate for you know
short-term financial not pain but you
know financial these things could have
really benefited particularly coming out
of the back of kovacs some of the things
i sort of walked into were to try and
you know protect these opportunities for
myself my wife my kids and all these
kind of these kind of things but what
what i did in doing that was
added things to my plate that wasn't
allowed me to really focus and like you
know to use what you said there was just
to go sort of narrow and narrow and deep
it was it was all these opportunities
that in the short term would would work
well but in the long term vision of what
i was trying to achieve and what the
covert allowed was to try and you know
get back into what is this long-term
vision um you know things are going to
get back to normal and there's a long
time ahead of us to get after this so
it was useful for me what are some of
the lessons that you wish ollie a year
ago would have known
um
i've kind of used used the term already
but just really being where my feet are
i actually took that from a from the
performance director at nike uh ryan
so
just being i guess just being in the
moment like being being in the moment
learning to appreciate that that each of
those moments i like i've said already
i've always been that person that's kind
of like that what's next mentality and
grass is greener and keep pushing it's
kind of part and parcel of what march on
really stands for but there is still a
fair amount of just like sitting back
and reflecting on where you are right
now and appreciating those times um
particularly a year ago where i was able
to have more better conversations with
the close people around me
um better quality time spent with you
know with family members
um so i think that that would be the
biggest lesson is just to
is to appreciate
appreciate everything we've done in the
past to get to where we are today and
just be you know live in the moment a
little bit better given that you're an
ex
elite level athlete who performed and
was always about trying to improve
trying to up their game
do you feel
do you have a sense of fear in the back
of your mind that this being present
nerfs some of the drive that was what
made you competitive in the first place
yeah i think that's a pretty good way to
a pretty good way to um to be i think
when you are a competitor at heart like
you're constantly looking for just like
that next bit of advice that next bit of
advantage like where can i go from here
how can i continue trying to level up
find that
that competitive advantage over you know
the people around you
um but it can be quite destructive at
times because you don't actually know
what you're aiming for you don't
actually know what what is next you just
think there is something there
um and i think
given
like i say just
the fact that we were like my business
and i know i've got a lot of friends and
peers who you know the business
unfortunately didn't quite make it
given that we were able to do what we
did in that time i should have just
appreciated that even though at the time
i felt as though life was was you know
with the door the doors of our gym
closed life was pretty miserable
there was a lot of things that were
going on
even just the growth of the personnel
around me as well you know the team
members within march on how much growth
they got from being able to adapt um
pivot that's a terrible word that was
used too much but change that you know
change the working conditions the
environment how we delivered our
products and services
the opportunities that we looked at that
we seeks um the development of all those
products as well
they grew tenfold in a year like you
wouldn't you wouldn't see that sort of
growth in an individual over that sort
of time um because it was such an
artificial tough time to try and develop
yourself
so yeah we've come out of it we're just
huge huge lessons and learn-ons and
all of us is much stronger for it
i think most people really don't
appreciate the price that high
performing individuals pay to be great
at their career so eddie hall's a really
good example of this the year that he
won world's strongest man i saw an
interview with him and he was saying if
i hadn't won world's strongest man that
year i would likely be either
dead and or divorced because his
marriage was on the rocks because of the
sacrifices he was making for his sport
his body was being i was like i think
he's only six one which in that sport
isn't actually that big
and was nearly 200 kilos so it was just
this sort of boulder of a human
wandering about blood pressure through
the roof and they nearly fainted after
doing that deadlift had to get put on
oxygen just
generally everything in his life was
wrecked but because everybody saw that
very narrow domain of competence that
they applauded him in yeah but he's the
strongest man on the planet
and he says if he hadn't given that up
he reckons that everything would have
gone kaput wouldn't have had a
relationship with his wife which would
have included his kids
would have maybe been dead or had some
sort of significant problems and what
people need to realize is that the price
that you have to pay to be that person
that you admire within a very narrow
domain is probably one that you wouldn't
be prepared to put your hand in your
pocket and write the check for you
wouldn't pay the price that you had to
be to be
eddie hull
and the price perhaps that you were
paying to be olly march on previously
was one that long term
you when you look at it you think well i
don't want to pay that i want to pay
this price i don't want to not be able
to
just train for the enjoyment of training
i don't want to be able to
always have to feel like the emails need
answering this is one of the things that
got brought up on the last chat that you
know 8 pm 9 pm 10 pm at night and that
was obviously because you were still the
linchpin that held everything together
because you hadn't scaled the business
down because you hadn't delegated
control you hadn't given these other
people roles to play in and i think that
this is it's something that every
businessman needs to a business woman
needs to understand that
as you grow within the business you as
the figurehead the forefront of what you
were doing
you can't be that if you want to scale
it simply doesn't work because over time
all that happens is more and more
pressure lands on your shoulders but
broader than that as you grow up as a
young guy or girl into the
solidify the kind of life that you want
to have presumably with a family
that also probably isn't scalable from
what you did in your 20s you know the
60-hour weeks they don't work the same
goes for what i do with the nightlife
stuff you know the way that me and my
business partner used to work staying up
till six in the morning to complete the
accounts and and run back over the night
he's got three kids now and i need to
wake up and i've got my stuff to do with
the podcast like that that can't happen
so everybody needs to let go of who it
was that they thought they were and you
see it with people that can't you see it
with the the punch-drunk boxer that
still is trying to win a world title at
40 45 years old you see it with the
businessmen who constantly sacrificed
their entire lives in a desperate
attempt to try and achieve a goal that
when they actually look at it they're
probably not that bothered about either
but it's difficult having the the little
tolerances taking things with compromise
it's hard
100 it's that phrase isn't it it kind of
it works that it doesn't um and i think
you know it's something that i sort of
preach with the guys we look after in
the mentorship is that a lot of us that
are you know running our own businesses
or working whatever we're doing whatever
we're doing this for it's constantly
trying to just draw the correlation back
to like why are we doing it
because a lot of the decisions we make
usually take us away further away from
what we're actually trying to achieve
you know a lot of them are financially
driven and of course because
more money potentially gives us more
freedom but
the life we want to live i always say to
the people we work with is kind of like
define your perfect day and let's work
back from that or the perfect week what
is that perfect job you know that
perfect day or perfect job role look
like and what you know what's the sort
of money we need to earn what's the
qualifications we need to go and get do
we need to go and acquire some more
knowledge how can we implement these
skill sets what's the environment we
want to try and work in be it you know
offices gyms whatever it may be
and once i think you've you've done a
bit of that that that work
then you can allow some compromise
because the thing that you think it
needed to be isn't necessarily
the bill and underwear anymore there's
this quote that i put in a newsletter
recently from john maxwell and he says
you cannot overestimate the unimportance
of practically everything
what he's saying is that the vast
majority of stuff that we do doesn't
contribute toward our higher goals for
the first time ever in human history we
have problems of abundance not problems
of scarcity too much food too much
convenience too many options for what to
do with our lives like
what is the thing that you want to do
where do you want to be in one or two
years time
and how many hours did you spend today
doing something that directly
contributes to that the vast majority of
people if they actually look at how they
spend their time it's not contributing
to the higher order goals it's just
doing all of the other [ __ ] that sits
around it like i genuinely think that
being
ruthless with
planning and then neutering everything
that doesn't contribute to that plan
solves pretty much every productivity
problem i i honestly think that that's
the case like and this allure of novelty
means that everyone's always compelled
to do something different to you know
you said yourself i've got to get rid of
some of the sponsorships and the
affiliate deals because they're
distracting me from my my core
contribution to what i do in my business
but it's hard this fomo fomo's a [ __ ]
hell of a drug it's that you use the
word as the that abundant mindset right
and it that that links also that there's
those routines we were talking about
during lockdown it's like
how much more can i put on my plate
until it's almost like just a man test
or a woman test to see how much you're
suffering yeah exactly yeah until you
until you break
um so yeah 100
how do you know when you're pushing too
hard and when you're not pushing hard
enough
usually the people around me will it
will will tell but i'm pretty self-aware
to be honest i think because i've got so
much lived experience from pushing too
hard or not there's not been many times
where i've not not pushed too hard to be
honest but i kind of know where that
line is now i know when i'm towing a
little bit too much i think also there's
sort of this kind of like flow state
mentality where things feel effortless
if things feel effortless you're able to
you know you've acquired that specific
knowledge of what you feel as though
you're the expert in or where you can
have the most impact in in that portion
of now the situation that you're in now
you no longer have that specific
knowledge quite so much you're venturing
into new territory you're not doing the
things that you used to do is there a
little bit of imposter syndrome creeping
in with with sort of where you're going
to at the moment
a hundred 100 but i've always i think it
is every sort of stage of my life and
growth through my career there's always
been imposter syndrome even in my
sporting career going from you know
playing club rugby in the national
leagues to going into a high performance
environment like england there's always
been an imposter syndrome but i think
again someone's trying to push
someone that's constantly trying to push
themselves is always going to feel that
so it's something i've dealt with and
kind of lived with a long time and i can
recognize it and
it's almost like part and parcel of
of daily life um
but i think
i think yeah the more i'm just getting
to getting used to this new chapter of
what you know where i can have impact
and i think now
you know before
seeing impact would be the look on
someone's face when they leave a
training session or you know or them
sending me that message afterwards
saying that was the best session i've
had in a long time or i've done this
i've done that or seeing someone pb
their left whatever it may be i'd get
that initial kind of return i knew that
i was having impact there and then i
think now
i hate these terms but yeah go ahead
looking at now the the figures of the
business and where there's growth and
sort of the key kpis be it financial or
just like growth of of different areas
something's got to be going right and
it's either the fact that i'm doing what
i'm doing now or is the fact that i've
delegated and put people and facilitated
in those roles where they're now doing
their bit right but there's still the
sort of proofs in in that now so
i think even though the job role is a
little bit unfamiliar to me and it will
become more familiar as time goes on i
can still see that i must be having the
impact that i've set out to have because
things are kind of moving in that
direction this is another thing that
business people as they grow up have to
understand previously you used to see
the look on your customers face when you
served them one of your signature donuts
or the compliment that you got if
somebody left your club night or the way
that somebody felt as they walked out of
your gym whatever
but then after a while you're all right
okay if i want to scale this up i can't
rely on
an individual person's
feedback like i need to be able to
aggregate the [ __ ] that's going on and
you're right like it's a bit of an ugly
or it's a frowned upon term to talk
about the fact that all the accounts are
kind of going to be one of the ways that
i look at this impact but that is an
aggregation of what's going on it's very
difficult to run a business badly and to
see it growing especially in a
competitive space like fitness
yeah 100 and those things really matter
now because there's a lot of people sort
of you know salaries and mortgages and
there's a lot of responsibility on those
things actually growing so i need to now
pay a bit more attention to it whereas
in the past it was something like it's
something that never really interested
me because i never really went went into
it
for all those things but i think as a
business grows and tries to scale and
has a bit more of a profound effect
i've needed to take more interest and
spend more time with the accountants and
actually look at these things in a bit
more granular detail
how do you deal with down days if your
mindset's not right
um
good question i've not had many down
days for it for a long time
apart from when i got covered that was
that was a that was a tough time um how
do i deal with down days
i think just going filling it with
things that i actually enjoy doing
um which ordinarily is kind of some form
of physical exertion because i feel as
though that's when i feel most alive it
allows me just to go to a place where my
my head can be emptied and i can be at
one with kind of thoughts and and try
and you know distill and filter out why
it is that i'm potentially down um
having conversations again i think as
i've matured i'm i'm definitely more
open about having conversations before
in the past i've been more of a closed
book um because
it's often hard to talk particularly so
male masculinity rights to talk about
feelings and and showing vulnerability
or weakness so
that's something that
has has definitely changed so i'm
willing to have those conversations more
um
but also just accept that these things
it's just their feelings they'll pass so
be it one with them for the period they
need to be there and go and do what go
and do whatever you can do to either
rest recover and make yourself feel a
little bit better by by your actions or
just accept that a little bit of time
will go past and you'll be back to where
you wanted to be
that's a really good insight the fact
that everything is just going to be
transient right it's here for today and
maybe today and tomorrow and maybe a
couple more days after that and then
it's going to leave and this is why when
we look back
on periods of challenge we can see them
with a little bit more equanimity and
actually maybe fall in love with some of
the difficulties that we've had now you
go through a period like kovid and at
the time you said this feels
uncomfortable there's uncertainty about
the future you look back and you realize
[ __ ] look at how much growth came out of
this
but at the time it feels really bad but
this this happens every time that
there's a challenge like it's every
single time you come up against
something it feels [ __ ] in the moment
you look back and you appreciate it
so i'm wondering whether there's a way
or i think it would be advantageous for
everybody to try and develop a way
where they can have that perspective a
little bit more perspective in the
moment like look i've observed something
in me this morning i've woken up and
i've felt [ __ ]
all right that looks like today's just
gonna be a sort of grip my teeth and and
move through it maybe i'm not gonna pb
today but that's all right like i might
pb tomorrow and if i just get through
today little wins little wins little
wins get to bed tonight right sweet you
wake up tomorrow and everything feels
okay like that's the level of
self-confidence that i think you want to
get to it's it seems to me like you have
quite a lot of of confidence in your own
ability even if you are pushing new
grounds where do you think that comes
from
yeah i think i probably got sometimes
too much i i often say if someone came
along and took everything from me i've
still got myself so i'll start again
with with wherever i'm wherever i'm left
i think
the confidence grows from just lived
experiences you know trying things
failing
learning from that trying things winning
learning from that
um putting myself in the firing line and
you mentioned about the other
this sort of like live in the moment
thing just then i think each day i try
and fill my day with sometimes too many
challenges but as many challenges as
possible
to make sure that when i put my head in
the pillow at night i feel fulfilled and
i've actually i've grown as a person in
whatever domain i'm kind of trying to
grow
um
i suppose a lot of people often say to
me that i'm always on the go i'm
constantly doing things i'm just trying
to live the life that i've got in my pot
and try and fulfill my potential i'm
trying to live life to the fullest it's
a bit of a wanky comment but if i do all
of those things like i say there's going
to be some times that are going to be
really tough sometimes they're going to
go really well i've been able to get
myself to you mention what i do what do
i do now and this kind of ties into it i
actually think what i do now is ride the
wave and the success of the people that
are around me that's fundamentally my
day-to-day what it's like now there's
people in positions that surround me and
kind of look out after me and prop up
who ollie martian is now so that a lot
of the success people see or the lot of
the
whatever you see of me is usually the
work of the people around me and you
know side by side by side um
so as long as those people are still
around i think i'm going to be all right
man yeah i mean this is another thing of
a businessman or a business woman like
letting go of you being the person that
drives the growth and getting in people
that are smarter than you or better than
you in a ton of different
places you know you look at somebody
like ben francis the guy behind jim
shark and he's now got like his md i
swear he used to look after adidas or
reebok or somebody
think like that guy's got 10 times the
experience that you've got you're still
head of the tree like you're still the
guy that's driving the brand forward
you're still the one that understands
the the real nuances about the
positioning with regards to the brand
and there's an importance to have a
figurehead as well there that's been
from ground floor all the way up
but you need to be able to recruit
people that's smarter than you
and then
applaud them when they do the work on
your behalf
yeah i just sort of looked at the
segments of kind of what was my gym my
my job role look like
when i'm spread too thin and how can i
start to like work with and offload some
of these bits to people who are just
more specialists who can just focus on
that but actually you bring up a thing
there you know ben france is probably
the
the person that at least someone like me
would you know watch all the youtube
videos and try and just take as much
from him as possible
in that for us to go to this next level
now sometimes i am left questioning
whether
i now need that board of people or those
people that sit above me be it someone
who's been a founder and taking a
business from you know the ground the
ground right you're right up be it
someone who's got
experience as a ceo be it someone's got
experience in whatever sort of sections
or whatever areas of our business need
expertise sometimes i'm left kind of
wondering like i don't need to go and
find that myself
and that might be how i actually spend
my time let's go and develop myself or
that area of my game
or i need to go and find someone that i
can kind of work with or they work with
me in that sort of
i guess overseeing role to make sure
that we get there because
everything's great for us
and we i feel as though we can we will
still move in a direction that is you
know towards where we're trying to get
to but it just might be too slow if it's
left just to me to do it particularly
the kind of ambitions that we have now
um
so yeah that's that's always something
i'm constantly constantly pondering over
it's like where where's the gaps in what
i'm where i am now and how can i you
know doing the social media things very
easy but how can i actually make sure
that the stuff that i am doing is in
line with the big goal the interesting
thing there is that that hasn't impacted
your confidence
that accepting that there are limits to
your capability that you can't be master
of all trades
hasn't made you feel like you're lacking
in some place and i think that this is
again another really [ __ ] important
lesson that it's like look it's not due
to a lack of capacity on your part that
you need to get other people in that
there are people that have specialized
in [ __ ] you don't try and do your own
accounts like you have an accountant for
a reason just roll that out across
everything brand design graphic design
operations logistics customer service hr
whatever the [ __ ] it is like all of
these different things are very very
specialized areas and just because you
think that you can do it like letting go
of that desire to be the guy that sorts
everything out is one of the most
important things that i think young
business people need to be able to do
let go of the [ __ ] tether to you
controlling everything in your business
find people that you trust slowly over
time stress test them see if they work
see if they fit within the industry see
if they fit within the company and then
let them run wild and just check in with
them and keep them motivated that's it
i'm at 100 the people that are
associated with our business now
pretty much have free reign to do what
they want you know the only thing we say
is like unless it's going to cost us and
we put a figure on like don't make a
[ __ ] up that's going to cost us this and
don't make a [ __ ] up that's going to
cost the brand this is its reputation
otherwise just get on get on make
mistakes fail fast move on try things
be innovative um
and it's not always easy right because
you can't just employ people and you
know all of a sudden you've got all
these people that you need to you know
you're constantly as your business looks
to grow and scale particularly business
like mine that's never taken investment
like we've never we don't have deep
pockets we're not backed by anyone it's
hard to be able to pay the salaries of
some of these experts that you need to
have on board um which is why i'm so
grateful that we've got this
aspirational brand that people want to
come come and work for because often
they kind of come in at a level that
you know is is a little bit
underwhelming take a hit on the pay
packet because they want to be
associated with a brand yeah yeah but
i'm kind of like look if we take this
punt and you come on this journey with
us and you can you can you can see by
into the vision that we're trying to get
to like i promise i'll get you there
like we will get there eventually we
just need to do these consider these
these steps first and foremost um
together and they're gonna have a huge
influence on that as well which often
gives them a lot of excitement as well
um but when we get there like i will
still i promise i'll still be the last
person to eat the table we just you know
as a small business we need to just do
things a certain way
so given the fact that you're not on the
gym floor anymore i'm going to tap into
your old training expertise a lot of
people probably kick starting a fitness
journey again after a big period off
jim's finally starting to get themselves
back towards a critical capacity
what are some of the biggest errors that
you see people making in your gym
and during your time training them that
are restricting their progress
um
it's difficult because yeah again one of
our things is like in the past it's been
trained everything ready for anything
but i think people that sort of my level
of training experience that have done
the sets and reps for a number of years
can kind of do that but even now i'm
finding i'm actually training for a
marathon now and even now i'm getting
frustrated because i'm doing all this
running but actually my goals aren't to
be a better runner and to obviously one
of my goals in the short term is to do
well in this marathon but i'm doing it
because it's almost like a bucket list
thing whereas it's not really one of the
the goals i've i would have for my
health and fitness right now
so it is just about trying to hone in on
what is it you're trying to achieve like
is it the person that's trying to just
move away from pain just have a bit more
better quality of life you know in
whatever years they're in right now is
about longevity and those kind of things
is it about the aesthetic or the
aesthetic side of things is it about
trying to build some strength whatever
it may be but just hone into as to what
the goal is um
because i think people just spread
themselves too thin again with this kind
of abundant mindset and particularly the
offering that fitness brings these days
you can literally do anything um and
they just throw as much stuff at
themselves as they can so the first one
would be pick your goal
yeah choose a goal and just like
focus in it i think a lot of people that
come into our world the functional
fitness space just haven't done the sets
and reps the sort of multiple muscular
contractions the general physical
preparedness
and they want to go and you know they
want their um
their their body well i can't remember
the phrase but something around the mind
is trying to catch checks the body's
trying to catch
the mind is writing checks that the body
can't cash you know they're trying to do
all these things they've seen other
people do because of social media and
things that they're not able to do yet
and there's there's like a this level of
just kind of earning the right in in in
the fitness world all right so let's say
that it's someone who's
got a few years of training behind them
maybe taking a little break maybe just
sort of ticked over with training what
are the
principles that you think like right
okay here are some [ __ ] mistakes that
i often see people making they're aiming
for getting in good shape they want to
be fit but aesthetics are also a part of
it
where are they where are people often
going wrong in your experience
so again linked to the fact they're
trying to do too much so just find that
minimum effective dose right we want to
play the long game first and foremost we
want to make sure that we still are able
to train relatively hard but we're
staying underneath that sort of like
that capacity where we're under
recovered going into our next session
particularly for people that aren't
fitness professionals or athletes where
they have to go and
perform in different arenas outside of
the gym be at work at home with their
family and what have you so
just make sure that you're doing that
minimum effective dose anything above
and beyond that is brilliant if we go
too far then we're gonna there's gonna
be a lot of diminishing returns i think
picking something again the modality of
training the environment that you know
that you physically really enjoy you
wanna be able to go to that place often
it's gonna either be before work on your
lunch break or after work
that you actually want to be there you
want to you want to be make sure because
that's going to boost adherence it's
going to have more buy-in
and it'll make the whole process more
enjoyable which therefore means you're
probably going to do it for a little bit
longer
um i would then try and surround
yourself i i either with a buddy that
you're going to go and train with or the
people at the gym or even just the
owners of the gym themselves or a
trainer with people that
motivate you can hold you accountable um
and again feed there's just that level
of enjoyment
um
and then just the low hanging fruits
just like don't eat like a kid you know
eat eat sensibly um don't restrict
yourself too much like make sure that
you are just able to to be consistent
you know throughout the week but you you
probably need to just accept that
there's going to be days that are going
to go better than others
make sure you get into bed on time just
the usual things i think most of us just
want to be training for to look good
first and foremost i do think that's a
big driver for most people but it's for
longevity and health and that really
just just needs a consistent mindset
right and playing the long game train
three to four times a week things that
you enjoy doing if you do want to build
muscle we know we have to lift some
weights and it's going to be stimulus um
eat well
sleep
like as well as you can
and jobs are good
i like it man
the movement that we've seen over the
last three years or so three to five
years which you've been a part of and
then other people like maybe james smith
have been a slightly more outspoken part
of it's kind of been this return to the
fundamentals
you know calorie deficit if you want to
lose fat progressive overload if you
want to build muscle make sure that you
sleep make sure that you eat make sure
that you get enough protein make sure
that you find a modality that makes you
want to train because if you train a lot
then you're compliant and your
compliance is the key driver of your
results
and the one there that people rarely
talk about
is finding a training partner or finding
a group of people that you can train
with that really really gas you up
because that's a huge difference that
having somebody
that you're in the gym with that gets
you out of your own head that gets you
out of your own thought process
and
encourages you to do some more reps to
do some more sets that holds you
accountable to the training plan that
you're going in there to do now
outsourcing your willpower to either a
class or a training partner
is one of the easiest things that you
can do you just need to find either that
person or that class
100 i think
outsourcing yeah outsourcing your
willpower to a program right so when you
go in there there's just something there
what the [ __ ] are you in there to do
yeah as opposed to i'm gonna walk over
here and walk over there yeah you
mentioned earlier on we mentioned sharp
monday and mindset david that's a big
part that what they've become now is
like everyone just shows up on those
days on the program so on the march on
program it's like the amount of people
now that are posting you know mindset
day and just you know then it's one in
everyone's in it for the same for the
same reason we we've we've said like
today doesn't really matter what the
scores are it's a competitive
environment our programming but it's
like effort is the only currency just
show up and put in the work and you're
going to have a good outcome um
i think you mentioned you know mentioned
in the same sentence as james smith
which is quite nice
but i think that
the key driver with that and the
messaging behind all of this from the
likes of myself and and him and you know
a lot of other people
that's been brought out born out of the
fact that i think now because all this
information imagery
what people's idea of fitness needs to
be and what people look like now in the
fitness space is so readily available
through social media
or on all these different platforms
we do need to bring it back to just like
the reality of how this [ __ ] actually
goes down a lot of what you see isn't
sustainable for most people and it's a
load of [ __ ] the basics done very
well consistently over time yes they
might be boring but that is where most
people are actually going to have more
success
and it's it's the people that just don't
get bored of the basics that will be
the people that are in shape year on
year
um when the others are just jumping on
bandwagons are gonna have so it's gonna
it's gonna ebb and flow
um but more often than not they're gonna
be in sort of troughs rather than peaks
there was a an interview that james
smith did with i want to say the head of
the chinese weightlifting team and he
asked him what the difference was
between the guys that make it to the
absolute elite that compete on the world
stage and the guys are just below and he
said that it's the athletes that can
deal with the boredom of daily training
the best that we look at somebody like a
matt fraser or uh you know an early
march on and we presume that every
single day they're absolutely gassed to
go and do like you know in matt's
programming if you've got 45 minutes of
modest structural work on a on a rowing
machine
no one's excited for that not even a row
is excited for that that [ __ ] sucks
but if you can man up if you can dig
deep and find yourself some motivation
to get you through that
that makes a difference that's where you
will grow
it's the same in any sort of area of
life right whether it's your training or
any kind of area and what you're trying
to do it's the it's those sets and reps
and it's the boring stuff that compounds
over time so long as you're doing the
right boring stuff that compounds over
time that's going to give you the
desired outcome we spoke about it
earlier like most people just can't
create order around those those three a
few things they can create order around
one or two areas of their life be it
that pertain to work or family but as
soon as you've got to create order
around the kitchen around training
around work around family around social
occasions
something falls apart it's the people
that have the ability to do those four
or five things
that then people think they've got all
their [ __ ] together they've just spent a
bit of time trying to create that order
find what works iterated on the process
when it does work just allow compounding
interest to to to take its you know take
care of things
when it doesn't work try and improve it
they don't have everything sorted they
just have the few things that matter
sorted
exactly yeah yeah and for most people
they can sort one or two the people that
you think have their [ __ ] together
they're just sorting three or four so
just get one
[Laughter]
what about fatherhood man obviously we
we touched on it earlier on you've now
got two boys and
wife and now juggling different
businesses and stuff like that what
about some of the learnings of being a
young dad over the last year
i'm i'm quite hard on myself i think
with this
and i think sometimes it's i think i
still i think it's just just justified
it's the bit that i find the hardest out
of everything why do you think i did
what do you and what do you mean by
hardest
i think
it just doesn't come naturally to me i i
get you know when the boys are crying or
if they're kicking off or there's some
like my patience is so
short so i'm like yeah
i i just it i get frustrated very
quickly like i've been left with the two
boys
you know a couple of a couple of
weekends over the last year
and i can do like one day and i'm like
where's my parents i need my mum to come
around here now and help me out
just
i think because because yeah because
they are just like it's so chaotic right
that you you can't create any sort of
structural routine you have to be so
and this is where lauren's so great and
i think where most mothers or or parents
that just get it they're so selfless
like it's like everything they they
exist for that day is to serve other
people
and i'm like that with most most things
like i want to serve everyone around me
it's almost just like a next level when
it comes to like a kid like a baby like
you need to be you need to just you need
to put anything that you had on that day
or that you wanted to get done to the
back of your mind because it's just not
happening in the way in which you want
it to happen
um
i also think
just just being able to spend more
quality time again because of the nature
of our business and the nature of like
how competitive it is and and
the the way in which i need to operate
day to day social media whatever it may
be
that can often creep into and leak into
times where i'm supposed to be well i
should be being present with with other
bits and pieces but at the same time
coming off the gym floor
and not needing to be in a particular
pace on certain days there are obviously
occasions where i've got appointments
but i'm now able to do things like
drop my son at school pick him up go to
these sort of things whereas in the past
that would have mean potentially taking
a day off work or off the gym floor so
there's been some successes some
failures but there's definitely a lot of
work on still to still to come i'm
fascinated by this transition from
business owner to fatherhood and and
letting go of some of the challenges
because previously
in a business
if somebody'd been kicking off as much
as your kids were you'd fire them but
you can't fire your own children
apparently
yeah
yeah i think the biggest sacrifice i've
made and it's actually something i
identified a couple of weeks ago
i don't need any violins being played
because i do have access to it you know
a lot more resource and time to train
with but the biggest sacrifice over the
last couple years i think is is actually
myself as the athlete i think i've done
really well as the as the business owner
and to drive the business and to recruit
well and and to keep that moving forward
i think
where where what's really suffered is
myself as the athlete you know and i i
probably play the age card a little bit
too much on this but come here 33 is no
great age but i'm definitely not in in
my prime anymore um i'm definitely on
the other side of that and being
surrounded by some of the young bulls
that are so good at you know on the gym
floor or or you know on the on the
training floor
i think that's the biggest sacrifice
that's something i want to try and
post this marathon really try and have
one last go at it have one i'd put upon
just that
i'm not quite sure i just think a bit
more pro just
again it's gonna probably me going back
to a little bit of that
obsessive person and something else
we'll have to we'll have to give um i'm
not quite sure what that is now but just
going back to the advice i just i just
said there is like just focus on what is
the goal now like in the past
i've resulted
if we're talking about myself what's
what's resulted here is like a jack of
all trades yeah and i know and i stand
by that still being the thing that i
want to be you know i can go i can i can
go and run a marathon on five weeks
training and do pretty well i can still
sprint jump lift weights go and compete
in fitness events that kind of thing
but there was a time in my life where i
literally felt invented invincible with
the sort of weights that i could lift or
what i could actually achieve my body
and that's not just there that's not
there anymore
so i just think there needs to be some
deliberate practice and just trying to
gain a bit more weight get a little bit
stronger get a little bit more robust
and actually go through some training
cycles and phases um to really try and
push the needle how long that will last
and whether i'll you know actually see
that through i'm not quite sure because
i don't really know what's around the
corner
but i think it was the catalyst was on
the national fitness games the other
week just like i'm just that little bit
off
the top guys in some of those
in some of those um
uh some of the some of the events it'll
be in the top end strengths off and i
don't have i want to have one last go at
it before it's too late that's something
that very few people have spoken about
i've never really heard anyone have a
conversation about this mean you the
same age
talking about what it feels like
to watch your
physical prime
fall through your fingers
like to watch that happen because
you see with elite athletes you know um
cristiano ronaldo's just gone back to to
manchester united and everyone can't
believe that he's worth this much money
like he's 36 in capital letters was
trending on twitter
because they just couldn't believe the
fact that this guy who's of that age
but outside of that it doesn't matter
that you're not an elite athlete
letting go of
what you used to be able to do because
throughout your 20s you know for all of
life you're on this sort of ascension
you're an appreciating asset physically
you're getting stronger you're acquiring
new skills your capacities are growing
up you're more robust you better
neurologically all of this stuff
and then you like start to feel you know
when a lift stops and you sort of notice
that you're floating up in the end
you're like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa i'm starting to and
then you go no no no don't don't start
going down like i don't go down
and
um it's i'm noticing it with myself like
injuries come more quickly recovery
comes more slowly
weights and progress
body fat's harder to lose
muscle's harder to build am i
okay
i need to accept the fact
that at this age
this is the direction that i'm going in
and the only way that i can get around
this is with sheer
force of will and and effort it's going
to take me more effort to achieve fewer
results than it would have done 10 years
ago
and that's a [ __ ] tough pill to
swallow
100
i was actually a couple weeks ago some
of the people around me actually
mentioned this to them we were sitting
on bournemouth beach um after the
competition it was a sunday it was sun
was shiny it was incredible
but for about 15 seconds i was just
having the worst thoughts in my head
about my age you know the day after the
day after the competition i had had a
few too many drinks the night before so
i was a bit hungover and i was just kind
of reflecting the people around me were
you know some of them were my age but a
lot of them were a lot a lot younger
i just had some really morbid feelings
about just like [ __ ]
i'm at this age now my prime's gone i'm
not gonna be that person again and all
these kind of things and
i wouldn't i wouldn't change anything
over the last
five six years at all but like say one
thing i've not really focused on is
it was a deliberate change like i didn't
want to focus on myself as the athlete i
just want to try and get back to like
you said i'm happy for marginal returns
so long as i can go okay for that period
i've given it as much as i could with
yeah every everything within reason of
all the other hats that i'm trying to
wear um whereas i feel as though there's
been a large period portion of time
where i have just been ticking boxes and
those boxes have served you know
i've ticked those boxes and i'll be able
to do other
do things some some great profound
things in other areas of my life to
allow to afford me the opportunity to go
you know what for the next year
here's the time and effort i'm going to
put towards just like
seeing what sort of athlete i can be at
34 years old you know what challenges
can i go and do what weights will i be
able to lift and numbers and that kind
of thing
um because i've just not for the last
let's say the last four or five years
that kilos on the bar where the times
hit and that kind of thing it's just not
even being of an interest of mine
and that's quite weird i don't like i'm
ready to just give that one one more go
[ __ ] interesting man
really
really is like quite a profound
thing to be thinking about you know i
don't know sort of what the equivalent
is for girls if they've attached their
sense of self-worth to something but if
you're a guy that's spent a lot of time
in the gym throughout his twenties and
then starts to notice stuff
happen like your metabolism is slowing
down so when i actually
it does i can't outwork a bad diet
anymore which i used to be able to do
like i genuinely can't outwork a bad
diet and it takes a little bit longer to
rehabilitate stuff and uh the hangovers
are
beyond [ __ ] otherworldly they they
come hard and fast when you're not
prepared for them
mate unfortunately i don't really cause
i don't drink that often i don't really
have to experience hang up as much but i
mean the hangover on sunday was horrific
but you brought you brought up the
injuries i mean yeah just like niggles
and injuries and even just getting
myself up for training like some days
i'd have mild anxiety about the fact i
had to train
whereas before i was like [ __ ] i want to
train all day every day yeah um and
there's a couple of young lads that kind
of work work from archer on that like i
said
they can do back-to-back sessions from
6am through to midday
like it's nothing run upstairs have a
quick you know bit of porridge or coffee
and then they're throwing ridiculous
weights that i've never even touched
above their you know above their head
and i'm like where the [ __ ] look
i'm never gonna get that back but i need
to get i just need to get some sort of
change
yeah just chase it down a little bit i
think just i've called it one last dance
we'll see how far i get with it
i still never hit the numbers that
they're going to hit but
i will i'll give it the best shot i had
a conversation with uh navy seal ex-navy
seal he actually created the
the mind gym for seal team six which was
the the mindset side of the navy seals
and um he was talking about the fact
that the the oldest age [ __ ] this hurts
so bad
said that the oldest age that you could
join the seals that was 28.
and i tried to i tried to sort of defend
the older i was like that 28 seems a bit
sort of he's like well yeah just
physically the guy's over 28 they're not
really there like if you're in at 28 you
can stay on but if you don't and he told
me the story about some guy was climbing
up one of those i don't know what the
grapple rope type things you know the
the rope nets climbing up cargo nets
um climbing up apparently it's like 25
30 foot off the ground on sand on the
beach running with a pack
this kid was 18 or 19 years old climbed
all the way up to the top got one foot
down and just fell 25 feet
to belly flop onto the sand with a pack
on his back with like heavy [ __ ] in a
bergen apparently just stood up brushed
it off him and ran it's like did if
you're in your 30s and that happens to
you you're snapped in half this guy that
was 18 bounced off the floor like a
[ __ ] rubber ball and just and set off
again you go yeah
yeah okay
maybe
i remember i remember in the in the
rugby days like in my early twenties
even mid twenties like the boys who were
considered the old boys at like 32 33
there was a couple of 35 yards maybe a
36 they've got kids they're married
and i was thinking like [ __ ] this is a
short career if like i'm only a few
years away from that like why why do
they talk and act like that like they're
old and now i'm there and i'm like going
back to rugby would like i couldn't even
fathom trying to snap
yeah i'd literally get snapped in half i
genuinely think i'd i'd last five
minutes
um
it's it's getting old is a very
humbling thing man and like we're all on
that path especially when you used to be
the you remember when you used to be the
young guy
like i used to be the young one and now
now other people are the younger ones a
lot of the people i socialize with now
are
five ten years older than me like that
sort of by by um
through kind of the the the career i've
had a lot of my friends now
have come through the gym and they're
members or what have you spent with them
and when i talk about being old they're
like
yeah you're still very young but then a
lot of the people i spend a lot of time
with as well people that kind of in the
fitness
arena
you know we had someone competing for us
every week who was 19 years old and i'm
like [ __ ] hell like a lot
23 24 25
and i know this that's not a huge
difference in age but there's a huge
difference in feeling between someone
who's 25 and someone who's knocking the
door of 33 so
got to make the most of it while we can
i love it man what's next what can
people expect over the next six months
to a year from you in the business
uh so a lot of people that kind of
follow our journey would have seen the
rebrand that kind of took place over the
last last couple of weeks um or last
month or so that's been a lot of work
that's gone on behind the scenes a lot
of internal research a lot of research
of our community people that that we
kind of look after
just trying to really understand if like
what we think of ourselves is that what
our consumers and our customers feel uh
where can we be better just constantly
trying to improve what we do so that's
taken place which is great so hopefully
now it's just like trying to elevate the
brand
to sit alongside it it feels weird
talking you know say even saying the
word brand right because again how do
you take it to a person you know yeah
because it's become something that
obviously when we set out we wanted it
to become something but it's kind of
like it's it's now happened so we want
to make sure that we everything we do
that comes out from the brand all the
services and things are of of the very
best quality that we can um as people
know we've got a bricks and mortar
facility i
might one of my biggest goals is to
own and operate a second site just to
see if we can be a multi-site operator
and hopefully that is a catalyst to then
go on to have multiple sites ideally um
so that's kind of what we want to do in
sort of the gym world in the online
space we want to just grow the the
online audience and the online
programming that we do we've been able
to fortunately get into multiple
different countries around the world
which is amazing and we just want to
improve on that the girls that sit
within nutrition
and doing an incredible job so again
being able to influence people's
relationships with food their behaviors
and the way just their relationship with
themselves right is the way that our
girls coach nutrition is honestly
it's it's it's so profound so
trying to try and develop that we've
obviously got our clothing on a
merchandise which is going through a
process of again improving what we do
there be the product the quality of the
products and also just the logistics and
how we deliver it um and then some new
bits a few people know this sort of
stuff but we're moving into sort of
sports nutrition and supplementation um
with some really real sort of core
products that we believe in and be it
for performance and lifestyle
um
so yeah a lot lots going on um lots
going on in the education business as
well
we deliver sort of level three
qualifications further cpd and also
mentorship so
i think just more of the same so what
people know us for we're just going to
keep you know on that upward trajectory
hopefully um
and i still think that there's a lot of
work that we can be that we is is to
come from
is to come from us and i feel as though
now we've got the rebrand out the way
and the personnel that have come on
board we are just about to get started
i love it man good luck over the next
six months olly march on ladies and
gentlemen people want to keep up to date
with what you're doing in the brand
where should they go
uh to be honest the only platform i can
get my head around is instagram so at
olly marchand is the best place um
you'll probably buy you'll probably then
see a lot of the team members through
that as well so you can follow them as
well
cheers dude
cheers chris thanks mate
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace